Americans head to the polls two weeks
from tomorrow with control of Congress
and much of the President's agenda
hanging in the balance a new Wall Street
Journal NBC News poll finds president
Trump's approval rating is 47% the
highest since he's been in office nearly
two-thirds of registered voters are
highly interested in the midterm
election the most ever recorded in the
poll and Democrats are still the
preferred party to lead Congress many
candidates are trying a new approach
this year they are opening up to voters
in intensely personal ads that go deeper
than the issues ed O'Keefe looks at some
of the ads getting the most attention at
good morning good morning John with so
many different devices competing for our
attention a growing number of candidates
are in far more personal style of
campaign ads it's not everywhere surely
some of you this morning are still
seeing attack ads but increasingly
candidates aren't just tugging on voters
heartstrings they're yanking will it
work well as we say stay tuned catchy
tunes and scare tactics don't cut it
anymore you deserve us this year the air
war it's closer to home we learned our
oldest has a rare chronic disease
pre-existing condition more intimate ads
more often from women candidates but a
pre-existing condition
hung over all of us even revealing baby
bumps and breastfeeding some say no man
can beat Larry Hogan
well I'm no man it doesn't work for
everyone but the goal is to go viral
raise more money and eventually win
share this by a TV ad and prove the
impossible
like Alexandria Ocasio Cortez it's time
she's a former bartender who being a
10:00 term incumbent with the help of
this ad this race is about people and
there's Texas Air Force vet MJ Hegar
whose take on doors one of my first
memories was at the door it was my dad
during my mom threw a glass helped her
break through don't want to make
something that looks like a typical
political ad those don't work mark
putnams team was behind the doors ad and
this one when I was 13 my congressman
told me I couldn't fly in combat
powerful personal messages some shot on
iPhones most of this year's standout ads
are by Democrats but some come from
Republicans like Ron DeSantis running
for Florida governor as a family man
filled the wall make America great again
or Brian Kemp this is Jake GOP candidate
for Georgia governor who takes aim in
his ad at his daughter's boyfriend two
things if you don't date one of my
daughters respect and a healthy
appreciation for the Second Amendment
sir people are thirsting for
authenticity they're looking for people
that they can relate to and they can
believe in given that there are so many
competitive congressional races this
year ad buyers estimate that political
ad spending will nearly match the almost
three billion dollar spent on campaign
commercials during the 2016 presidential
election and while this style of
advertising is especially popular in
social media
most of these ads are still airing
primarily on local TV Norah it's
incredible to see that the personal
always connect yes
personal always connects Thank You Eddie